my name is maitrey rahman and i'm from
bangalore in india
my host university was the ludwig
maximilian university in munich i worked
in the lab of professor aura cartel at
the max planck institute of biochemistry
the
benefit to
my tray was that she learned how science
works on a day-to-day basis
my research project in particular
focused on cellular models of
huntington's disease which is a
neurodegenerative disorder that is
extremely debilitating it causes a
progressive loss in memory and muscle
coordination
and it currently has no cure when they
leave our lab i would really hope that
they were able to get a glimpse of the
excitement that science can provide
growing up i didn't really know where to
call home i was born in india but then
we moved to malaysia and then china
singapore and vietnam and now i'm
studying in london
each time we moved i was thrown into a
new school a new set of
people and a new culture so everything
constantly felt like it was changing but
the good thing about moving around so
much
is that you begin to find the things
that you want to make consistent in your
life for me one of those things was my
scientific education i always felt a
sense of comfort in knowing that
scientific knowledge is the same no
matter where you go
so actually the amgen scholars program
was the first time that i was able to
contribute to a substantial research
project
i'm really grateful to be a part of
something that could potentially lay the
groundwork for
a cure especially for something as
debilitating as huntington's disease
my mentor eugene and i grew tremendously
close when my theory came to the lab and
she asked me what her project would be
my approach was to try to get her to
tell me what the most interesting part
of the project was to her and she really
encouraged me to ask lots of questions i
think the amgen scholars program is
really great different people are
successful in taking different tasks
it's all about finding what's right for
you and a good mentor can help you make
kind of informed decisions at every step
of the way
the quickest way to improve yourself as
a scientist is to just throw yourself
into research that interests you and see
if you have the aptitude for it and if
you enjoy it
i would definitely recommend the amazon
scholars program it's life changing